audrey a 17 ans à la recherche de
babysitting ponctuel elle a participé au
premier babysit dating organisé par la
ville de Montini le principe organiser
des rencontres entre les parents et les
jeunes à la recherche de garde d'enfants
terminal donc mon emplo temps me permet
pas de pouvoir avoir duting tous les
soirs de la semaine donc c'est
occasionnelle quand les parents ont
besoin on se retrouve avec 47 parents
inscrits plus de qui sont ven
aujourd'hui on a plus de 50 jeunes qui
ont répondu présent on est sur une
demande de fête un peu particulière en
cette période de l'année on a
effectivement plus de parents en
recherche de babysit occasionnel et on a
plus de lycéens effectivement en
disponibilité c'est très bien comme ça
on reçoit tout de suite les CV on voit
la personne et en plus les enfants
rencontrent la personne en direct parmi
les quatre candidats qu'elle a rencontré
Vera a réussi à trouver une babysitter
comme elle Élise une autre maman n'est
resté qu'une heure à sa table de babysit
elle a néanmoins récolté une douzaine de
CV dont celui d'Audrey j'ai trouvé
Audrey très souriante elle a un
excellent relationnel je pense je pense
qu'elle se débrouille déjà pas mal avec
les enfants pour ce que j'ai pu en voir
je pense que je me suis assez bien
vendue qu'on profile a du intéressé tu
as fait combien de famille j'en suis à 5
donc on verra ce que ça va donner pas
mal c'est pas mal et là c'est fini pour
toi ah non je jusqu'à 18h parce que je
veux je veux continuer le plus possible
et avoir le plus de famill possible pour
avoir peut-être derrière le plus de
rappels possible des jeunes motivés qui
consacrent un après-midi entier à la
recherche d'enfants à garder la
concurrence s'annonce difficile mais
Audrey possède une arme
secrète je suis très forte en
scouidou